it's another lab hang out super excited
to be here with you and my good friend
Steven Kelley CEO sage who's in London
again Stephen welcome back stretta
vieira ready in two of these sessions
today we are talking about how to be a
visionary marketer I know a bunch of you
already asked a ton of questions it's
great to see the live shots throwing in
time you can want to ask the question
you do / q and then start typing a
question afternoon come in even before
we get to the question there was a lot
of them already came in I just wanted to
get your thoughts on what's a visionary
marketer looks like lessons frontrunners
kind of alleble overview from your
perspective and what's what being a
visionary marketer moons yeah i think it
was and it's such a critical area the
business I think everybody is not just
answer it's had a UK creative community
be in the conversation guitar and this
is probably the one area of businesses
transformed and she totally different
council at was 30 years ago so if you
look tougher you know the experts while
Phillip copper or someone 30 years ago
he'd set up to Moton and selling digital
become his church changed ever so we'll
talk about a lot of really useful stuff
I'm sure on this black around how do you
meet yourself at the center of the
conversation and you kind of create that
volunteer community of interest and had
you really meet the customer need
something you say it's a really exciting
but you know the thing that scares me is
this is such a vast topic and there's
just so much we could cover but I think
your keepers honest to keep us focused
on all the audience issues so they want
to address
I love it that there's a there's a
little bit of noise coming in and out I
don't know that people are mentioned in
the comment view but the microphones not
much so we'll get another touch it will
get another bite don't worry doesn't
mind maybe another headset and figure
that's for me if you're looking at being
a visionary marketer I think it starts
with having a vision you know
surprisingly a lot of you look at most
marketing in my view is not visionary
it's boring it's stale it's you know I
want to click away in my view you know a
company should stand for self I think
entrepreneurs get this a little bit more
than most big company because we've
started a business around our passion
and we are here for a reason and we want
to get our message out there to build a
better world somehow you as
entrepreneurs and in my view marketing
should be about providing value still to
your customers I think too many people
see marketing just as a way to sell and
if your marketing is distracting if your
marketing something people want to click
away from then that's not something that
is really adding long-term value to your
business in my view that's not visionary
marketing in my view you want to have
something that when people look at it
changes their lives it sparks something
that makes them think it makes them want
to go out and do something more which
may include buying your products as well
but the marketing itself is value it's
not just trying to sell something and I
think if you look at the most visionary
and most valuable campaigns one that we
still talk about 20-30 years later it's
because when you see their marketing it
makes you think about your life in your
world and what you want to do with your
business as opposed to just oh if i buy
that i'm going to get high percent off
so i'm going to go for and so I think
that is kind of the biggest difference
for me it's understanding what your
vision is since you're like I'm a
visionary marketing standing for
something as a business and then letting
that seep into every marketing channel
you have so that the consumers see your
vision and they want to help you on your
path to make a better world although the
key thing is ever a love that ring key
thing is how do you stand out how do you
differentiate
you big part of the conversation and
years shape of the composition and
that's really what am I it is the heart
of the business and I think it's also an
you connect emotionally to your
consumers or the people in the business
business abroad so there's there's loads
to go because I think this is a rapidly
changing area and it's a great way to
differentiate & Company marked it
shouldn't be as you said it out its core
to what you stand for it is it's almost
the marketing is the company the company
with a heart and it is right they will
come together I don't know what we're
hearing you better now it's good good
work on the tack oh great well let's get
to the questions first up longtime
viewer loyal blabber and are already
giving tons of processed everybody here
of gr eyes what exactly is marketing
according to you guys like people toss
around the word every business basically
but it could be argued by simplifying
your brain or speaking controversially
or any number of things our marketing
could you clarify please Amalia so um
you know in the other Senate you went to
business school water 20-30 years ago
they talk about promoting and selling
products or services I think the digital
world has changed everything everything
through social media is transformed it
and I think it's harder now than ever to
stand out because we're operating the
sea of noise so just looked at some
stuff coming in today every minute
there's 277,000 tweet sent posted you
know 106 216,000 the photos uploaded to
Instagram so you know there's so much
noise out there now morphed i would say
in today's world is how do you actually
connect yourself and be in the
conversation with your customers and the
community and how do you want more trade
that we'll talk about you know keep be
focused authentic and and marked it does
lead the way for the product and you
talk about brand the question talks
about
and the brand is the essence and the
focus of you know what you said in the
other crap how do you with your product
or service were really changed the world
how do you get that excitement in a
compelling vision where people get
excited widgets and you create the
conversation you're part of the
conversation as a by-product to that is
sell a lot of stuff but you start with
what's really important finding the
conversation and service in the need of
the customer you want is it using the
waters the custom need how can you
invent that and fundamentally then how
do you build you integrated marketing
plans and strategies to be driving that
conversation being part of a
conversation what do you think of it yes
I mean for me markings about getting
your message out right so we start with
our vision here's the message here's
who's a better world that we want to
create and in marking is how do we tell
the world about this how do we get
people to join our mission jump on board
this bandwagon get on this rocket ship
and let's go change the world and so
there's a lot of different ways to do
that because marketing I think a lot of
people just think I need to take out an
ad a newspaper on your web and Google
eyes it's not just an average height
range a rocket point yo simplifying your
brand can you be marketing if your brand
is too complex nobody else are you
staying for and it's boring and it's
Sonic and sale then simplifying your
brand can be a huge talking point right
if you get it to the point where people
can understand what you're all about
then that's awesome marketing speaking
controversially I wish more brands more
entrepreneurs did speak controversially
I wish people did stand up for something
that they felt was important and
different and valuable and you know if
you want to change the world that means
you're upset with the status quo somehow
right so get upset speak controversially
right I want to tie onto that leader
who's guiding that [ __ ] forward and so I
wouldn't be boxed in by typical
definition of market that you may find
in a textbook market is good how do you
get people to understand what your
message is all about and there's a lot
of different ways to do that and so you
know Thank You Jay Roger that great
question and the beam of the highlights
of the more kind of controversial points
around it do you how do you guys do your
marketing Steven or are there new
uh campaigns that you're lashing at
you're really excited about on the
markings height that kind of gum you got
to be a little about reverse what about
you know living the lives of
entrepreneur's working hard you know
using your life savers to grow your
business the anxiety of line making
payroll painting supplies managing your
business grow and exporting whatever
dishes so kind of mocked and point
number one is we've got to be where our
audiences you've got to go where the
audiences and we're going to fill up
same issues I do think Martin this is
unlike what what's that he is it it's
very emotional now there's a huge of the
you know I talked last time with you
having about companies with a heart I
think we're trying to connect both
through marked in our hearts with our
audience and you get in very much into
the areas of how to drive the emotion as
well as their kind of thoughts so we
think I'm definitely with our products
and we're doing this in things we've
built call the customer businesses where
we take what are the all the issues on
customers have and there's a product
with optical searchlight when we
crowd-sourced all the requirements where
I users more business owners of
accountants and entrepreneurs just say
what are they need for technology of the
future that will allow them to run their
business much more efficiently and focus
on what they love doing which is winning
customer searching customers and grow
their businesses and therefore we built
a product up to about 51 days actually
and then we launched it and this is
where it's different is marked and kind
of used to be a little function that was
an afterthought now it's kind of front
and center because the product is
marketed it is distribution it is all
totally integrated so we go through and
we build these up your integrated
digital marketing cell service in hubs
where we actually and we've had
customers come in 30 days from hitting
the web through buying a product but
they didn't the the initial thing was
all about the conversation one of the
issues they face it how we solve those
issues and that was we refocus the
effort and there's a bite right to that
they've all product and then we help
them through again many digital tools
the whole onboarding process
sitting out like we're getting customers
life in less than 30 days off right so
you know it's awesome in terms of kind
of really changing what we do but but a
point to make is around marketing what
10 years ago would have been something
we think about in a rear view mirror
we've got product launch how to do it
marketer traditional channels get all
the 4 p's and stuff like that it is and
then advertising oneself it's very
different now it's much more integrated
process it starts with the user it
starts with weather or Orion siz and
then it talks about how we be part of
that conversation especially through
social media and it's a totally
different world now I think through our
entrepreneurs out there there's some
really good lessons that we've got
probably we can share a chance how do
you get your products or services to be
part of that conversation how do you
make the issues that differentiate you
because it's all about standing out how
do you stand out you know Seth Godin all
these great people all these marketing
geniuses they all say it's all about
stand that differentiating it's all
about getting found first so when they
get the website when they do a Google
search how do you jump out the page and
look different not just look the same
old kind of corporate stuff not really
different and address their needs in a
radically different way and it does i
think definitely have to include the
rational and solve their problem but
have you appeal to their emotions well
how do you kind of get engaged around
something's exciting propelling and
really again I'm evangelical credit you
know Raven a raving fans via product I
like that evangelical I like the first
four letters of I love the oddity so one
of my favorite quotes on on marketing is
these hackers the marketing is too
important left to the marketing
department and it's something that you
like as an entrepreneur you need to
leave right like you leave with the
heart does lots of tactical you know
head how two examples but it needs to be
like Stephen said emotional something
impactful something that when I see your
marketing I want to make a change in my
life you know that's what I want to see
in the marketing campaigns that you guys
are creating let's pop in on some other
the question so Rishi cup another loyal
viewer she called in last time for us
when I think visionary I think innovator
it's easy to look at what everyone else
is doing and do that can you share a
time you found success innovating in
marketing thank you I seen ya is she I'd
say and what was I got here on a digital
market I'll give an example a real
example when I was in a start-up I had a
really great rock star marketing near
Warwick and this is way back when we're
in the start back to California in 1997
and my challenge it's pretty crazy like
we're no name company and I think the
problem we're trying to solve is when
consumers called into that bank or
telephones of the verizon or AT&T you
know they got passed around customer
service was appalling I'm we created
this great technology that allowed you
to have a single view of the customer so
any of us falls in for all these crazy
1-800 numbers they can actually be kind
of and so they didn't then the company
could deal with you as an individual as
a human being and understandable your
product relationships with that
confidence so literally looked at the
main I said to New York you know the
challenge is how do we with income six
weeks get on the front page of things
like Wall Street Journal or financial
times and this was kind of pre-digital
pre-internet what the internet was just
going embryo and then how did he do it
he said right let's connect ourselves
back to what we talked about what are
the issues that consumers really feel
what is that frustration when is that
anger what is their only when they're
hanging on for hours on these customer
service calls and then they get passed
around or they get a given another one
800-number they've gotta call you know
the anxiety and aggregate of customer
service and then what we did at she was
a really intelligent survey where we did
you know it's very simple low cost it
costs we sort of ran the company on
fumes which is a great way to kind of
think mentally as an entrepreneur it's
not about spending big dollars so we did
a really small customer survey got about
sounds of people and then it was like a
shock horror story and you know what and
then on the Monday
after six weeks it was on the front page
of the Financial Times in London and we
got calls inbound course and your the
thought leaders on this issue you're
absolutely right here on the money we
want to talk to you so I think that was
an example that was the end of the
marketing area where is all about
promoting and selling and push it and
now we're in a different world it's all
about pull it being part of the
conversation it was so much easier now I
said this on the last question of
secrecy on when you are on master is
what two three years three months years
ago now happens in three days and
through the power of well you know what
happens doing here with this around
believe are really poor focused around
seven entrepreneurs and inspiring them
to really fulfill their dreams and
pursue their passions this correct
clarity great sense of purpose and I
think that is is a I gave an example
from 18 years ago but thats still serve
as well so the lessons learnt there is
marketing dollars doesn't solve any
problems the real issues are what Evan
said is marketing is not a kind of
adjunct is poor the business a martin
really should speak to all the
entrepreneurs kicking off their
businesses about what we need to do to
meet customer needs how do we actually
connect the emotion for them to solve
their problems and take the frustration
out of their lives and they're having
really simply and articulately in a very
focused way and then relentlessly cheap
to that focus hit the button in terms of
what their issues are and how we solve
their problems and then market it and I
think we'll probably talk on this lab
around how we market through social
media and digital channels because that
that is the way because you could be
part of the conversation and throughout
that conversation you know they'll buy
at a point in time when they're ready to
buy Evan what do you think I just
looking in the comments and top stake is
recommending that you did a weekly blab
answering questions from your clients
and having your staff interact with them
live so the feeling the blab love here
my thought on this you know I think you
can pull a lot suicides a little
curveball yes I think you should be an
innovator and at the same time I think
you can also pull from other in
I think to too many times you're locked
into here's how to do things in YouTube
world or in dancing world or in you know
whatever business that you're in where
you can learn so much from other
businesses and other industries and
apply those lessons to your company and
and that's what makes you you because
because you like League of Legends and
because you like you know dancing salsa
because you like surfing taking lessons
from those industries that I've worked
and applying it to be the first one in
your industry to do it I take insane
amount of knowledge from league of
legends from baseball from music from
things that I just love and that makes
my business better where other people
are industry don't they're doing the
same thing to everybody else is doing
and in an example one thing that helped
lift my brand was the first big video
that I made on YouTube that that blew up
was around believed and I got a God of
collaborate with me who did a bunch of
motivational videos and nobody in the
entrepreneur space and have her
collaborate with him were done anything
similar and I work with him because I
liked his video and I was just watching
for my own interest put it up on YouTube
a bunch of people who I respected I
showed it to and they said that's too
long it's never going to work don't do
it that's where the little man idea came
from so that you've been trained to the
channel that may not work over a million
views and that was my first big reader
that took off and that was from taking
an idea from a different industry in
applying it to mine and so your other
interests are fuel for you it's money
for you take what you love about John
Lennon who's your favorite singer and
apply it to your business because he's
already figured out a ton of stuff even
though it's in a different industry
there's less as I can apply to your
software company and we figure out that
that's going to help you be a little
introduction we're in the office up in
Midtown up in London hey I've got katie
rose she's got a direct answer that
question could she just come on as a
little guest cameo 30 seconds here you
go here you know thank you hi Evan hi
hey we were actually just talking about
like fashion marketing of fashion houses
and I'm guess I'm kind of here
like the Millennial voice so as a
millennial we were talking about how the
main way I want to consume fashion now
what means a lot more to me than like
traditional runways it's like street
style and like burgers and what makes me
want to buy about is not these glossy
photos of it on the runway but like a
photo like on the vogue Instagram you
know an it girl like cool really cool
looking honor your place is great and
she's like hang the bag that that's what
makes me want to buy that bag and and we
were talking about how it's much more
about buying the lifestyle and the story
and and you could link that to things
like humans of New York you know he
knows New York like that everyone who
doesn't know the really like viral
facebook page of house about like buying
people's stories and buying find that
more than the actual product see that's
my many low interest rate love it look
thanks I'm great okay thank you hey we
love it I love it it did my lip fillers
you got an accounting software company
here learning from another skinny in
don't read this and I kind of think that
it was Richie you get this everything's
about the heart that companies with a
heart connecting with consumers with a
heart it's all about the emotion and
being in the conversation all the time
and creating the excitement and the blur
between kind of business and saturation
of life is is is gone forever so you've
got to be there right in the
conversation all the time and you've got
to be found first an exceptional over
these there it's got to be you got to
jump out a page and then from that point
onwards have everything authentically
consistent with what you're talking
about in terms of the message from a
marketing way through detroit right
through the service everything's got to
kind of match that up and you've got to
do with honesty and invariably you
though and i know every business has
things you've gotta fix you got to be
honest with those you I think it's a
much more excited business while we live
in now than ever before I love that
extension that you just took us down
because a lot of people stop with the
marketing where it has to go on to your
product of your service
finishing that you have because people
buy something based on the market and
they get the product and it sucks where
that vision has to go through when I
load up your software or when I load up
your fashion magazine or when I come to
your dance class I want to feel the lies
that I got any advertising I mean you
don't make that connection people are
gonna they're gonna drop and you're
going to get negative word-of-mouth
spreading so thank you for taking us
deeper because I think a lot of people
just stopped at the marketing and don't
realize that the product is also
marketing the service is marketing how
you deal with your customers are two
emotions or a motion is to company I
love it okay let's uh get to our next
question and we pop it up here this one
is from exit outlet that GRI is posted
for us on his behalf marketing these
days is evolving as audiences are
becoming harder to see and meet
face-to-face with online presence
growing what are the best ways to reach
out your demographics in the beginning
before you can simply by the audience of
the big personally I think young again
some of the things being disruptive the
example gave you almost 20 years ago you
want to be shown how I actually be part
of the conversation how do I get found
first and I think to Evans point you
don't want to do the same old boring
content but there's loads of obviously
digital channels are where you can
connect with your audience and I think
number one to point number one go where
your audiences find out where your
audience is and go there and you know
could be Instagram could be Facebook
could be Twitter and then what is the
exceptional or scented content that you
can server that speaks to the excitement
of your product or service and then then
I think you know our view of life st
then it's all about recruiting the
volunteer army it's all about excited
people when they get hold of your
product they tell all their friends you
know Here I just I just saw a drone that
takes video footage also also called
Lily check it out online check the
YouTube and if you're a skier or you you
dance classes you can have a little
drunk line around above you watching all
your moves is just all so it's got a 20
minute battery
but that that is if the products half as
good as YouTube video then it's just
going to blow away and it's going to go
viral and it's going to create a
community and the best what you do it is
it's almost like recruit one volunteer
fanatic who's using your product and
that person will give you a hundred and
those hundred will give you 10,000
there's 10,000 media hundred thousand
because products that are awesome
services are also it's all about being
referred by the viral economy I love it
I just fly the drone that alpha testing
I think they're built in you know this
other one will check it out only rented
out on youtube have a crisis gesture but
if you were mad ski out or you're one of
those concepts or something crazy like
that then you would have just a ball and
it kind of matches down it's almost like
a bird of prey comes back down when you
want to cause them awesome right so
here's an opportunity to be visionary
because the guys who are going to do it
are the skiers are the surfers are the
whoever like be the entrepreneur who's
walking down the street changing
questions right like whatever your
business is be the first to take this
and apply it to go image that every
skier is going to start doing it but
nobody's doing it in software so how can
you be the software guy to do it or how
can you be a baseball player to do it
right these are opportunities to
leverage what's beans views and other
industries and apply to your business
which may be a little more open on that
as well I'm wondering this change right
you remember the old madman message all
around a map a metaphor around kind of
advertising it was like think she'll do
seem feel do and that was sort of the
advertisers process the world's change
again so it's about do-si-do thick and
there's interview says to do feel think
engage the conversation and it's not on
one people with this stuff it's all
about the competition and then people
will buy when they're ready to buy but
what it means is if you just started up
as an entrepreneur the first thing you
got to do is do and then feel think and
also that the instant measurement or
analytics on on digital is so powerful
if you've got it wrong you can do real
quick course correction and you can kind
of do
the next campaign you treat the next day
with a whole different sentiment to make
sure you kind of get it right to find
out what you want you know where the
audience is and now it's how do you get
the audience sentiment and the audience
frustration and express that in the way
you're going to sell your products and
solution to well and so I do think the
world's changed again it's guess no more
kind of man my metaphor it's all about
do feel think engage the conversation
you've got to be harder to conversation
you're getting some love in the comments
they're saying thank you mr. Kelly
that's it and you're over 2,000 props
already in thumbs up so that's great to
the question my view on it is I think as
an entrepreneur you can't do everything
I think too many entrepreneurs try to do
everything you you have accounts on all
the social media platforms and you're
trying to post everywhere and as a
result everything is mediocre because
you also have a business to run and show
you're just posting boring stuff and
because people say oh you need to be on
Instagram so then you get on Instagram
to and then you're posting more boring
stuff and nothing is working out for you
I would say when the Stevens Point
figure out where your audience is I
would couple that with what are you
great up being able to do like are you
good on camera and can you make video
are you great at taking pictures and
kinks on the Instagram right are you
great with words and can you write blog
posts or LinkedIn post go to Twitter to
a couple where the audience is with
something that you're naturally good at
and then can destroy and dominate then
you don't need to spend money right my
youtube channel has 200,000 plus
subscribers and 20 million plus views
and I've spent zero on advertising
because I pour my love into the work and
because it's good people want to share
it and that should be the goal of your
marketing whatever you post don't just
spam stuff out there if you're going to
make an Instagram post be proud of it
creates hoping that you want to show
your grandkids and say look with Grandpa
Evan made right grandpa will ever made
right like you're proud of what you made
and then people will see it and share it
and then they become your army like
Steven said through sold out that letter
so yeah I think what you've done is
awesome and gosh huge respect for you
and juror you're a legend in the world
of entrepreneurs and gaming as well you
know I know I know you love it I know
you like it's your letter doubt it but
one thing I massively respect also that
you've done is the focus you apply to
your message which is really compelling
and easily kind of that the word believe
the focus and relentless focus and
consistency how do you value for the
entrepreneurs out there kind watching
today the relevance of the focus and
simplicity I think one it's super
helpful for yourself just it like
believe is my guiding principle I
believe everybody has one word that that
guides them or just have to figure it
out and I think too many people live by
accident and are living by reacting to
things in the external environment set
of purposely setting forth to create a
plan for themselves and as entrepreneurs
this is something we can do right we're
breaking free of the box of typical
world and we're creating out to create a
better one for ourselves and the people
around us and so understand what you
stand for helps me one with like making
decisions like Jesus about believe or
not if it's not I'm not going to do it
right ah you know I love working with
you guys I love having these sessions
there's a lot of companies that I don't
work with because you're not about to
leave because they don't care about
entrepreneurs really just want to sell
product and so having that one word
helps make a difference for me to say
yes or no to and also helps keep me
motivated like I have a big goal I want
to help a billion entrepreneur's you
know part of what I do the things that I
create I want it to be at scale you know
I love helping one-on-one entrepreneurs
it feeds my soul but I want to be able
to have a huge impact and so making
videos on YouTube right in my book doing
speaking engagements you know the things
that have the potential of reach massive
audience and have massive impact right
more than just Denton universe right
this is what I want to create and so I
think having that clarity and focus
helps as entrepreneurs because you're
doing too many things you're everything
from the CEO to the janitors you're
responsible for the marketing as well as
product creation as well as customer
services
was cleaning up you know the shop and
you know being able to focus on these
things only helps so in terms of
marketing again I will come back to you
pick what you're really good at
naturally talented that combined with
where your audiences and just focus on
that and they'll get distracted by
people telling you we should be on
linkedin or you need to be on Instagram
if that's not where your audience is and
what you're not really good at I mean I
believe in believe it's it's everywhere
it's well the dosage of what I just
looked again the level of spam in an
email creators 20 billion a day say so
it's just no good to do what everybody
else is to it because no one reads this
stuff you gotta go where the audiences
to Evans point find and really seem to
unlock their dreams in terms of products
and services be part of that
conversation and then the consistency of
focus it's so compelling and and you
gain huge trust nothing Evans says it
always about authenticity it's a really
undervalued word but also tissa t of
everything and and that's how you create
this volunteer army of Raven fanatics
who are your best salespeople that your
fans and they believe in what you're
trying to do an HR unchanged world and
they get excited about a fight and you
know and I know when you get excited
about some of you see some really cool
technology you tell me friends about it
and literally you've told hundreds of
people fails to follow us within seconds
I'm so excited right now I'm getting hot
I want I almost want to take off my
hoodie it's too hot the energy is
awesome in here grey / ah there we go
next question so this one was asked by
AG bola who wrote in the state the
services i render our accounting
auditing taxation management consultancy
my question is how can I market these
services professionally well so I mean
you deal with accountants all the time
you see tons of different entrepreneurs
how can how can they market them do you
have a really good question so first
thing simple things if you want to
connect us you've got my email address
so I'll leave you up to something called
the accountants sage accountants network
we've got 100,000 accountants is part of
that part of what we do is product
services any entrepreneur who wants to
have a local accountant comes to the
stage accountants network all kind of
obviously Google Maps enabled and you
can find it accountable skills and
relevancy whether you're in construction
or whatever they hospitality or whatever
industry that I think the other thing is
this is selling vodka see the the what
you have is the brand is trust and
competence and I think with with all
these things it's always going to be a
referral business so you get your first
two clients and then it does go it goes
it goes completely seismic in terms of
how you can serve more plants and I
think the challenge you have is once
you're successful is how you keep the
quality of service and maintain that
quality of service you know it's easy to
do for your first 20 clients but when
you get up to 2 300 400 clients then how
do you actually maintain an Excel
exceptional now think on this there's
some really good ways both ask that
other companies are doing some awesome
work of what we call real time accounted
integrated payments from your website
your shop window on the world right for
who eventually management all these sort
of things so the manual handoffs and
where you need a lot of sort of people
at the bookkeepers and stuff is is
changing and the rules that you could
play is almost you can reserve a lot of
stuff is what we call frictionless so it
kind of goes straight for it's a world
made it your run your business for the
pamir handle a smart rain and the role
of the accountants like yourself can be
tremendous in terms of almost virtual
finance director CFO's of all your
plants and you can say you know you cash
flow forecasts how do you raise finance
how do you go overseas how do you get
contracts to work out in Europe and
places like that so you can play much
bigger role I think and actually drive
up your revenues and you will value to
your clients because you're offering
much hon tani servicing kind of point
number one there's a lot of channels
that can help you sage is one of them
point number two is your business is all
about opposite building the first
network of clients and they'll recommend
I saw what entrepreneurs do what they go
down the Chamber of Commerce what they
go to the gym wherever they go they'll
recommend you a lot of people and then I
think you could build up a few social
presence around that the other thing i
love you to do if you want to is build
really good content so when it comes up
to the tax year easy stuff how to help
your clients move much more quickly a
lot of its automated and you could build
a really good kind of website shot
presence where they not only can get
hold of really useful information but
some tools to actually help me more
efficient in their business darling a
lot of stuff going on and a lot of
disruption and technology that you can
take advantage for me i would come back
to we're talking about visionary
marketing what's your vision I mean you
tell me what you do but what's the
vision like how are you different what
are you staying for as an accountant
because if I need would your accounting
auditing taxation ASA consultancy
there's a thousand people more like
hundreds of thousands of people I could
go to for this service why am I going to
pick you up ola what's so special about
you what's the better world that you
want to create how do you send out
versus everybody else that's what I
would lead with and then when you're
creating content when you're talking to
people that's what flows through as an
example there was a lawyer friend of
mine here in Toronto who was trying to
send out when he started legal practice
and he this guy loves entrepreneurs like
really like has a soft Spartans Hotch
entrepreneurs somebody that obviously I
would be able to connect with easily and
he changed his branding to be the
entrepreneur friendly lawyer a lot of
lawyers aren't seen as being friends of
entrepreneurs we don't like going to
lawyers it's so like it's a worst-case
scenario kind of things and so that just
that once wicked being entrepreneur
friendly made a huge difference in him
he will get his message out and people
didn't relate to him in him standing out
from a sea of lawyers because it's tons
of them so the same thing for you you
know all of the all of the practical
stuff we've been talking about the
content the application amazing but what
do you say for like right now we could
be helping you with some high level
stuff about your vision and how to have
a major impact in
world but I don't know enough about you
how you introduce yourself matters right
so it's great I want to know what you do
but more importantly I want to connect
with who you are as a person what you
staying for is an individual and the
better world that you're trying to
create make me feel something I'm
getting excited are ready for you
because I feel it's in there put that
out in every communication and that's
going to like people talk about you
connect with you wanna buy your servers
if I refer you on that as well it's
amazing if I go on to do or accountants
kind of websites once thing I think they
could a lot of people do is tool to
their customers so their clients since
you know why don't we have kind of
usually tip so that your plans out how
you change their business how you have
you created millionaires how you allow
people to live their dreams and allow
them to focus on their business and you
took care of all the back office and
just made that absolutely see how you
help them explore how you help them set
up you know maybe set up finance and
allow them to accelerate their growth
and it would be great to assume you know
you just tell your iPhone along
everybody wants to do it because you're
given them free kind of marketed you
talk about marketing if I'm a client of
yours and I'm growing my business at
three hundred percent a year I'd love it
if I here on your website there's a 30
second download video of me talking
about how fantastic services are on how
it'll help you explore to Canada back to
the UK over to you know fazil and to
stuff like that and then the story again
connecting the emotion I'm connecting to
making it just it's all about people
it's all about connecting the heart and
I think come to Evans what just a simple
thing today will be good and go and do
kind of videos of you customers at the
end of the tax year and how are you
assure them their sleep well at I love
it next question borrowing varun how can
a person who is not a marketing
professional convinced people to invest
in his business is hiring a networker
the only option or can he do something
himself so marketing now in terms of
getting an investor as opposed to going
out and getting customers what is I mean
you're you're an angel investor you put
money into companies we've talked about
this in the past too but now in terms of
being a visionary
you know I entrepreneur pitching the
angel and after you want a boy same
thing we talked about this which we
should actually probably come back and
do a separate blocks because I know it's
a big issue for your audience out there
about how do you grow your business how
do you raise finance what's the
different ways as you kind of grow up
scary business right from start up
through the you know its people I think
obviously kind of point number one back
to the conversation how do you stand out
how do you let him know what her know
that this is significant market
opportunity but how do you how are you
different from everybody else what's
your renovation have you lead from
people and then also how cogent
incoherent is your plan for execution
and it's not like bought in the ocean
but it's like what do you do next 30
days 60 days 90 days with water the
current revenue forecast what is your
plans around or we talked about today in
terms of marketing customer engagement
product all the areas of the business
that are fundamental to being successful
and I think at the end of the day you
need to convince that individual is
about the management you're gonna you're
gonna be the guy that he can trust or
she can trust to grow their business and
then take good care and be a green
custodian of the finances and Sons that
they've lent you to really grow your
business and I think the most important
that you gotta you gotta get excited so
it's about what is your three what is
your passion and what is your experience
to make this a reality so that's the
thing you've got to go to even with and
how do you stand out because you know
and I'm at these guys see hundreds and
thousands ditch the thousands of people
probably every three months so you know
they're if they're kind of seen 20
companies a week then what do you need
to do to really stand out when they go
home and have a glass of whatever they
want to drink it a weekend they remember
that session safe that's the one I need
to invest it yeah i think if you if
there was ever a time for visionary
marketing it's in china raise funds
because all you have is a piece of paper
right you haven't created anything yet
all you are selling is your dream is
your vision right like if you're if
you're selling the customers you have a
product or something you can show them
here i'm selling air i'm selling i'm
selling my vision and so for me this
something that you hire a networker to
go out and help you find this is you
what sells it is your passion your
excitement your experience you know I
want to if I'm looking at a company to
work with I want to see that that
entrepreneur how's the fire I want to
feel it right so yes you need a business
plan you're not going out with no
business plan you know that's not a
recipe for success but the business plan
is it's just paper like you need to sell
the business plan with your passion and
excitement and energy and this vision
that you want to create that most people
may say is crazy I believe that you are
going to will it into existence right
that's what that's the fire that I want
to get from any entrepreneur who's
pitching me as an investor and so I
would do it myself I would taxing to the
passion of what I want to create I would
make sure that I'm doing this because I
want to create something for a better
world not just as a money-making
opportunity and I think you could do
that then then you'll be able to get the
right investors on board not that it's
that's still easy but I think it's
better for you to do it yourself and to
try a higher net yes it's got to be
yourself yeah it's all about a few
questions over lunch LCL at the end but
i would do if i was looking to raise
money from an angel I don't also
probably work with a millennial build a
website in two days maybe build a
prototype do some YouTube videos and
show them what it could look like so not
just so kind of stare our business plan
but what jumps off the web browsers what
will the shots and aerial right and just
take them through the first three
screens and show them what the
experience of the consumer might be
because now it's all about help them
visualize the generally dinner on how
you're going to know absolutely kind of
crush it in terms of your dreams make it
reality but a great way of doing that is
not just kind of pages of word process
and stuff but it's actually seeing stuff
visualization of stuff and then it will
so you just think about if you went to
do a presentation everybody else does a
presentation they do PowerPoint slides
and you actually show them the product
and you shouldnt the website well that's
different that's really awesome love it
love it okay next moving on we've got a
lot of questions here Tim hello Evan
Steven I have a question about tactical
execution against the vision
a strong vision sets direction and
enables the whole business to focus on
outcomes but what are your top three
recommendations for creating the vision
that has high tactical value in other
words a vision that everyone knows what
to do with and how to execute income
with the vision is really important to
have a place or end result an outcome
what is it you know your your mission is
about launching and helping millions of
entrepreneurs you know sages vision will
be to launch the next 10 million
businesses and create the foundation for
millionaires to go and help their
communities creep yuge prosperity in
jail pressure so the clarity around that
mission that rallying cry is really
important and it has to be in result
bounce so you know what are we going to
do by 2020 and how we going to change
the water how we can and then I think
you need to bring it down some very
tactical things in terms of getting back
to what we talked about before it's not
about the old world it's not about think
they will do it's about to first so this
the kind of thing we're going to do
tomorrow to achieve that what we're
going to do next week what are we gonna
cheat and get really tactical really
focused and then I do things really
important this business that a business
is fully integrated now it's not
marketing's in that jumped it's not an
afterthought is right at the arm
business and and how do you think about
being where the audience is and being
part of the conversation throughout and
what's that journey law way so simply so
it's free things one is have a big
vision big running cry know where the
journey is going to take you a number to
kind of be really clear about what the
milestones and the steps are there and
then number three is just get on and do
it you know to crack on and do feel
seemed engaged be part of the
conversation yeah i think my perspective
is to add a little bit on that is i
would be attached to what you're trying
to do but not how you're going to do it
how changes a lot right if you have a
clear vision so i want to help
entrepreneurs right I believe when I
spur gonna have a billion entrepreneurs
that's our big you know what what I'm
all about that influences down to a
tactical level because anything that I
do has to have big scale values right so
doing one-on-one meetings
I'm not doing that anymore unless that
person has an ability to go out and
reach millions of people right so I'm
doing much more in the public eye when
I'm directing my team right somebody
helping me with my youtube videos or
somebody helping me on my social
accounts and somebody help me with my
website having that big vision helps
align them for what we all want to do
but I'm not locking them into how to do
it I want them to be creative I don't
want to just give them always here's
what you have to do because then you we
work with a bunch of task managers
instead of people who can actually
projects and so your vision in my mind
helps you create the big picture where
you want to go but then when you drill
down it can give you ideas and I see it
more as the as the lens through which
you see the world as if I'm going to
make this next Instagram post is this
believe or not is this YouTube video
believe or not does it tie into our
mission or not but then not restricting
people to say you can only do this you
can only do these three things because
there's probably a lot of things that if
you can unlock the creativity of the
people on your team around the mission
of the all understand then they're going
to surprise you with a bunch of amazing
initiatives that you would have never
caught with yourself because hopefully
they're better than you are the skills
that they know and that's why you
brought the mines person coz you know
this vision is hallucination with
execution so to your point Evan a sore
about course correction you know worse
of what I would say is on a sunday night
you know you're probably catching up on
the paperwork from all that sort of
stuff but also just carve out like 30
minutes to reflect almost reads on well
this week what would really really well
actually what didn't go so well where we
going to change next week how in the
dirt is just an example I hadn't met
Evan and my life was a lot for 18 months
ago now ever nani's business plan
probably never knew that existed and we
got together and we thought actually
let's have some fun together and that's
actually we've got such a lineman
between our mission and our purpose and
sense of purpose we want to change the
world so why don't we do something
together we just started why don't we
just do you know a Google
hang out together and obviously we love
to reform if you get that we really
enjoy it because it's it's all about
serving you guys make it a difference
and supporting a billion entrepreneurs
is awesome but also hopefully will
provide some value every time we do one
of these ever my kind of reconnect what
what's the big issue out there for the
next one what we do better how could we
serve you as an audience better we never
stop learning you know we're always kind
of at the end of it beat ourselves up
hopefully we do a better job for you
guys and we're never done on that
journey so it just just shows you it's
more of Acts if you should get it on
with stuff and then staying true to your
vision being a company with a heart and
just pursuing your passion I love with
somebody at somebody wrote bromance in
the comments there I yeah I love it and
it's funny because I mean to Stevens
credit to I think one of the first times
we connect was on the floor of sage
summit and we just decided we would pull
out a camera and just start recording in
so many CEO as I can't tell you how many
I work with who are so like afraid of
spontaneity and saying the wrong thing
and having everything being you know
what's the question in advance and
having stage answers and it's always a
terrible answer it's always so corporate
and that doesn't connect with
entrepreneurs and see was really just to
jump in like yeah let's do it you know
you we don't know what questions are
coming up on this blab you guys ask them
where answering them trying to be as
genuine authentic as possible and you
know credit Eve Stephen as well for
prefer be nice you know no safe just is
one thing we sell on the blacks that
makes a difference to your business
sweet things are the sage foundation
there's a great charitable organization
it says just one life we change then
that are you know we saw just very
humbled I'm very privileged to serve
love it okay next question be different
on trip asking do ads work in this noisy
world or if not what could work to reach
your audience with your bizarre great
questions um I think y'all justjust
Naruto spam 20 billion emails a day okay
either can I take a Liberty can I
introduce the guy talked about a couple
minutes guys this will finally a worgen
rocks don't digital marketer figure it
is yeah hey there you guys great Wow hey
it's the Morgan right ranko conversation
and join the conversation so the
question of our ads working in this
world of thousands of impressions a day
that we will see I think I think more
than ever we've got the chance to get
ads in front the people using the
platforms that are out there and I think
there's one thing encourage people to do
if you're not already doing it is take
advantage of think things like Facebook
advertising you can go to Facebook we've
all put our commission that we've made
available the place would love to see
you use to target people based on any of
those demographics any of those
behaviors any of the grease atif on
where you live kind of business you're
in all of those interests make targeting
advertising much more cost-effective for
a small business might not have a big
budget we're seeing costs of leaves in
the dollar to two dollars previously we
might have seen in 100 for two hundred
dollars but just I use a great Facebook
targeting thirsty secondly if you go to
your Evan comic we've got an amazing
following on YouTube or Facebook you're
posting great conversations you're
getting great content and engagement on
your content don't forget to put some
money behind that the most effective
form of advertising to see today is
organic post boosting in the news feed
you might love it what is my haters but
as a business a really effective way to
drive the engagement of great
conversation afraid organic content to
make sure you put money into that
Facebook budget it might be twenty
dollars a day and not get hundred
dollars a day they're always feed in
facebook and twitter in one of your
platform mystification I'm right Robbie
for hearing you thanks so messed up is
that I am do that yeah so for me I think
I think advertising is one of the things
that you can do I think to Neal's point
if you are going to advertise I think
Facebook is the best way to do it
because you can get so targeted with the
people that you want to go after right
if you want to target
moms in Omaha who love Oprah Winfrey and
do yoga you could do that on facebook
it's never been easier to get shots to
sip retargeting so if you're going to
advertise that would be my number one
platform where they most people think
adds of like you know advertising a
newspaper in a magazine or banner ads on
websites i think i would do it through
facebook is my number one test with
advertising his test test test test make
sure it's working out you know Neil
can't ask to say that a lead cost him
one to two dollars and he knows that
he's converting it as whatever X percent
and that leads the customer that's what
you want to do I think as we move
forward it's going to get harder and
harder to make advertising work unless
the ads are fantastic and you see ads as
content right the ads are not just
selling something but the ads add value
to my life and I think every
entrepreneur should be telling their
story in the various platforms with
passion because that is you have to be
avin Carmichael you are you and starts
telling your story and tell me why you
started your business while you're so
excited about highlighting your
customers and what you're partying about
and that forms a bond with people and I
think I think I think content is going
to be the answer is going to be only
more important as we go forward whether
you're doing blabs or YouTube or
Instagram or Facebook or whatever
authentically showing yourself you know
just like sage is doing here you get a
chance to talk with the CEO of sage
answering your questions you know we're
not here pitching sage software and how
great it is you're going to go buy now
sage software cuz it's the number one
account Assad for hoorah you know but
the next time you guys have an
accounting issue and you're thinking
about software hopefully say she becomes
one of the companies that you look at is
like the default company because see
steven has shares such great knowledge
and now showing your team I kind of like
this for another team members here
because of things that you also the old
business-to-business water it's
incredible 75-cent the research is done
by the customer before they actually
make any calls so if you're not in the
conversation right at the star guard you
you you're kind of running running to
catch up the other thing I think is
really important
you sort of said it you know look at it
ever calm I could believe it's about you
but fool you passion your energy and
love and and the mission you're on
around change of the world for
entrepreneurs you know if I look at
Richard Branson rock star you know
virgin he speaks to a hill girl he'll
say hi gone are the people that could
put you out of business and things have
really resonate to every hospital and
you look at Anaheim Martians creates
great fashion again awesome in terms of
the brand personalization and tues yes
I'm ready Dali singing we have it summit
around those awesome shoes they were
design beautiful waivers you could see
the energy and the love that she had in
terms of you know making stilettos zero
pain and stuff like this so too I think
when you look at some of these people
especially in the world in a noisy world
of advertisements a sea of mediocrity in
many ways and just noise noise noise how
do you stand out again it's all about
how to use down now and really make your
product the inspiration of what you want
to feel in terms of the passion around
the business and I think that concept it
does come about yourself if you're
comfortable doing kind of YouTube clips
and stuff like that then people really
get there and then it up to you to talk
in terms of the advertising and then if
you can do create the fire alarm at the
volunteer army via customers there's
nothing more powerful than seeing
customers love and your product I'm
getting excited and be part of your
community and following you and really
connecting you into their world and and
all that sort I love it we're a time and
our flies super quick man it's crazy um
anything any kind of final words or how
can people find out more about you or
the things that you're up to no good and
with that Twitter a little anybody get
out there yeah I'm very approachable
you've seen some of the guys in the team
as well we're generally here like
yourself heaven we want to change the
world front
to give you guys the conversation is so
you know make the same mistakes that
I've made but I mean this is the time
where you know it's at a very emotional
so it's kind of human human aah and
you've got to connect with your
customers it's not the old world leaders
in VBS human-to-human you've got to go
where the audience's the product is the
brand is the advertising is the
marketing the authenticity of all those
coming together is so compelling
powerful you've got to be out there and
you've got to be found first and that
comes through focus and simplicity and
really kind of delivering an impression
and and also if you want to follow me
I'm i do a block as ever knows is quite
controversial but I'm trying to kind of
say let's pick out as they say in Europe
the elephant in the room as they say in
Canada let's put the mousse on the table
and let's be honest about it would stop
and entrepreneurs being more successful
what how do we kill red tape bureaucracy
and crazy tax laws stop you guys being
successful so I write a lot of things on
behalf of the community of entrepreneurs
to say we should call this out this is
not fair and it is absolutely suffocated
the engine room of the Canadian economy
and the US economy in Europe so we're
back at you we're on your side and we
love doing these things so thanks very
much you keep the questions coming yeah
I love it I rise online said you were
mentioning Sir Richard Branson and he
wants to see Cersei on Kelly so if
there's a petition for that I'll find
out let me know we'll get that going
Stephen is super fish at the time thank
you guys for joining in too i know we
didn't get all the questions but i will
do another one soon I promise have an
amazing end of the week thanks awesome
thanks hello guys right if they get but